>> Judge Jeanine: IT'S TIME NOW
FOR ONE MORE THING.
JESSE, HIT IT.
>> Jesse: TODAY IS A VERY
SPECIAL DAY.
I THINK WE KNOW THE REASON,
JUDGE.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
[CHEERS]
>> Judge Jeanine: THANK YOU,
THANK YOU.
TO CELEBRATE HOW AMAZING YOU ARE
WE PUT A LITTLE MONTAGE OF SOME
OF YOUR BEST MOMENTS.
>> Judge Jeanine: OH NO.
>> HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
'S THE BOTTOM LINE AND THAT'S
ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
THEY DISRUPT ME ALL THE TIME.
>> Greg: WHAT THE HELL IS GOING
ON?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: SCREEN JEAN THIS IS
DEVIANT.
>> Judge Jeanine: DID YOU CALL
ME GEORGE?
FOR THOSE OF HOW KNOW ME I LOVE
CANDY.
I HAVE SOME OF MY FAVORITE YORK
PEPPY MINT PATTY.
EVERY TIME I EAT ONE OF THESE A
COOL BREEZING THROUGH MY HAIR
AND WIND AA ACROSS MY LONG
FLOWING DRESS.
>> Jesse: OH, BOY.
>> Judge Jeanine: THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: DON'T RUSH.
SPEAKING OF SWEETS.
WE HAVE RIGHT HERE.
>> Judge Jeanine: YELLOW CAKE.
I LOVE YOU.
I'M NOT EATING ANY OF IT.
>> Jesse: YES, YOU ARE.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY.
THANK YOU, I WILL.
>> Jesse: SPEAKING OF SWEETS.
>> Judge Jeanine: OH NO.
>> Jesse: A SWEET HOUR OF
"PRIMETIME" 7:00.
THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSING THE
NATION AT 7:30.
CHECK OUT OUR COVERAGE THERE.
>> Greg: WE BAKED A GUN IN
THERE.
>> Jesse: NO GUN JOKES.
>> Judge Jeanine: GREG, YOUR
TURN.
>> Greg: TONIGHT GREAT SHOW I
GOT INDICATE McENANY.
KAT TIMPF.
GOING TO BE A BARN BURNER.
AGAIN, DON'T BURN ANY BARNES.
GREG'S JOB SEARCH, AS YOU KNOW A
FEW MONTHS AGO I JOINED LINKEDIN
I WANTED TO HUNT DOWN SOMEBODY
THAT HAD DONE ME WRONG.
THEY HAD ME PUT DOWN WHAT I DID
FOR A LIVING I PUT HOST AND NOW
GETTING ALL THESE NOTICES FOR
JOB OPENINGS.
MY THIRD INSTALLMENT OF ITEM
THEM HIRING HOST OLIVE GARDEN.
CREATE FIRST AND LASTING
IMPRESSION WORTH IT BOTTOMLESS
PIT OF WHATEVER.
HERSHEY PARK FUN CREW CREATING
MOMENTS OF SURPRISE AND DELIGHT
FOR GUESTS AROUND HERSHEY PARK.
THAT ONE I WOULD TREAT
SERIOUSLY.
LAST, WENDY'S CREW MEMBER.
NOT REALLY INTO WENDY'S.
THE LITTLE GIRL USED TO THE
FREAK ME OUT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO GREET EACH GUEST
WITH A SMILE AND WARM WELCOME.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO MULTI
TANK.
>> Katie: YOU DON'T QUALIFY ON
THE WARM WELCOME SMILING PART.
SORRY.
>> Judge Jeanine: JESSICA, YOUR
TURN.
>> Jessica: MOST DELICIOUS CAKE.
BECAUSE ALL I TALK ABOUT IS
BABIES.
HERE WE GO.
AN AUSTRALIAN MOTHER INTERESTING
APPROACH.
PLASTIC BOTTLES TRIES TO
TRANSITION HER FROM
BREASTFEEDING AND AFTER NOTICING
THE BABY WAS RECEPTIVE FROM
DRINKING FROM A PLASTIC SYRINGE.
PUT FORMULA IN A CLEAN TOMATO
SAUCE BOTTLE.
SHE TOOK TO IT INSTANTLY.
IF YOU ARE STRUGGLING TO YOUR
BABY TRY A TOMATO SAUCE BOTTLE.
>> Greg: AUSTRALIANS ARE WEIRD.
>> Judge Jeanine: HAVE YOU EVER
WONDERED WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO
MOVE INTO A NEW YORK CITY.
PROVIDING YOU AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
THE EXPERIENCE TYPICALLY GOES.
ALL COLONEL HAS TO SAY NOT
IMPRESSED.
CAN SOMEONE GET HIM A BIGGER
BED?
THAT'S IT FOR US.
"SPECIAL REPORT" IS UP NEXT.
BRET, DO YOU WANT SOME BIRTHDAY
CAKE?
>> Bret: JUDGE, HERE'S THE DEAL.
HAVE A VERY, VERY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY.